hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to probability 0 the game
that is a roguelike platformer filled
with destruction the likes of which I
have never seen it's actually a really
cool game I've been playing it for a
little bit so that I'm not too much of a
new when you guys all see me and it
features a lot of retro elements that
are from that golden era of gaming that
not a lot of people remember because it
wasn't all that good to begin with so
this game in particular features a lot
of those similar styles in this right
here is actually a level transition and
not what's gonna kill me and I got very
shocked by that the first time I saw it
now what's interesting about this game
is every time you unlock another level
you get to get these upgrades to your
abilities and these upgrades to your
abilities allow you to do many different
things now what's the point of most of
these I don't necessarily know but you
just keep going down and down until
you're ready to continue on with the
rest of the game and then when you get
hit by an enemy you get hurt like that
and you got to collect their souls to be
able to unlock all the duty daddy that
is coming your way once you get or -
damn it it's really frustrating because
there's only certain ways to go about it
and you can break these things right
there to get the percentages up but god
damn it when you're in the air your only
option is to shoot down and I wanna you
can't exactly punch midair these enemies
because they're gonna be [ __ ] about
and not gonna let you okay what are you
in there no no no no let's woman it all
around okay we're okay you'll stay away
from me now this isn't necessarily a
rage game oh I can break otherwise solid
and fun breakable blocks knees wall 20%
farther Vanguard stance pain hardly so
good
mm-hmm painting ham ham memory use every
part of the star what does that even
mean I don't know what that means that I
wanted so badly okay so you continue on
with the game
down and down until you finally reach
the end of it quote-unquote but there is
no end of this game because you're just
gonna be continuing until you die a
horrible death filled with death
poisoning and on a punch in your gonads
I want to punch a lot of things in their
gonads you're just coming son of a [ __ ]
don't bump me like that oh god damn it
I'm gonna run out of things I'm gonna
die a very early death what are you good
give me that no no oh and that's what
happens when you fall to your death you
die that's a game the objective of game
is that there is no end of this game
like the roguelike games of pass of
yonder year you just keep going until
you go on forever and then I did not
waste who my stars ain't gonna see why
valuable that was and how stupid of me
it was it oh God for you mr. spiky dick
how about you go ahead for yourself how
about you go to hell and die and also
die okay cool
get punched you douche get your soul
thank you
alright so this game can't get quite
frustrating because yeah so that's the
great thing about this game you can get
trapped into a cycle of death over and
over again and I was actually doing much
better at this game when you guys
weren't looking because then I didn't
have to try to talk and tell stories
about the Golden Age of gaming under
passed where there is node back in my
day we played our games on a spork with
an abracadabra machine and if you didn't
know it in every ticketed app or a
machine was you were oh you're not dead
you take do it
your douchebag come here you dick that's
right give me your thing throw me into
the rainbow oh god damn I forgot that
you don't keep your stuff after you die
[Music]
so this game you literally just play
forever and ever and never until you die
a natural death it no that's not what I
okay I guess I'll - no okay take fall
damage why don't you damn it I hate this
game so much but it's oddly addicting
like most of these roguelike games you
keep playing it because you're compelled
to keep playing it because it's not
gonna lay I already don't like this game
I know I'm trying to defend it and then
I'm trying to like this game whatever
it's just that these games are so
frustrating when I'm trying to talk
nautilus your guys's fall you all are
beautiful lovely people and I love each
okay each and every one of you to death
but it's just what I have to try to
concentrate over and over in a fall
damage was a good alternative to what I
wanted to do when you have to do this
over and over again it's gonna be a
giant dick bag to you over and over
again and you're trying to concentrate
so hard to talk and do this at the same
time you don't even understand how
difficult and I may be taking the long
or the wrong upgrades or something like
that come here on a punching punch no
you're so punch punch
oh that one oh god yeah and also there
are all those statistics that it's
showing you just to depress you this
game is meant to beat you down it's
meant to rob all feeling from your feet
and then you're supposed to go on with
life why would you get bounced into
oblivion over there well get a dick bag
are you God is the earliest I've started
sweating playing a game I'm trying to
take this calm and collected but it's
impossible when you're teeing so
frustrated because I know I'm good at
this game I was just doing the good and
you got all K you're gonna can you shut
the Frick frack up for two seconds you
stupid [ __ ] monsters I know the punch
isn't probably a good one because they
never actually punch oh okay hit the
spikey over and over again
I'm gonna lose my mind early in this
game aren't I I'm gonna have so much fun
playing this game over in the ugh anyway
I was talking about the olden days of
gaming and you're gonna get punch no no
I can't punch sideways when I'm in the
air come here come here
hit your death I got my fists of fury
ready to fish you in the buttocks no no
oh god this is such a son of a [ __ ]
people really don't even realize what's
happening me have it all now let's
follow damn it's good I can't well
that's a good alternative okay I need to
calm down for a second here because I'm
really trying to focus on this I really
want to give this a good try and be able
to play this for you guys and showcase
it I do have some skill in gaming I've
been playing games for a lo miss it good
why not why not why not miss it it's
gonna hit my head no I was gonna punch
it oh really no god damn it just okay
[Music]
I wasn't even looking one hit me I don't
even know I don't even know anymore just
get over your work and punch you no
don't shoot okay there we go I'm dead
I'm really really trying to focus here I
just want to show you guys that this
game can be fun is worth the money now
this game actually is kind of pricey for
what it is
although I god damn you to hell the
punch is so gosh darn useless this one
through okay shut the Freak back up just
let me go I'm really really not all that
happy right now
oh this son of a [ __ ] game is not gonna
beat me I damn it who's not being fun
right now I swear I was having I got
down to like 250 meters 250 meters is
what I did before I started recording
okay you know what I'm gonna stop trying
to destroy the monsters because I think
that's my problem there are these star
blocks that you can throw stars at home
these Starbucks like right below me that
you can throw stars at and that will let
you progress and if I just time oh god
miss bull yeah and if I time it just
right I'm gonna be fine
yes ah how about that cuz that way at
least I can send them flying over like
that well that doesn't help me - God
darn nougats Paul worked out better than
I expected to - okay so as you can see
doing a little bit better now the
statistics aren't getting nearly as
depressing as they were there we go okay
give me your soul I'm at a hundred
percent new winner
Oh what happened I thought I was okay I
thought it was gonna be okay I thought I
was gonna have a happy day but
apparently this game wants you to do
everything but I have a happy day all
right you son of a [ __ ] you wanna come
over here to my fits of fury come over
there oh never mind I'm gonna die that's
exactly what I wanted to do to fool you
did you think you were gonna win when in
reality you did over and over again oh
you know it's odd about this game I know
no one's gonna be talking about the
actual game or how much I'm failing at
it don't trap me in this box it's not
gonna be the conversation that's not
gonna be the conversation in the
comments I already know because you all
have already started typing it and I've
caught you red-handed you're all talking
about my hair aren't you you're all
talking about how it's not in a fauxhawk
aren't you you listen to me I can make
my hair whatever way I want to it's my
hair and my life go oh my god that spiky
actually saved me from a death most foul
that's experienced but that is the case
isn't it my hair is in a Novoa because I
was busy or something and I've recorded
late I don't remember why I have no
thank you so much it boosted me up now
I'm gonna get okay no no no no never do
that why don't know departs would be on
one of the blocks alright one more try
guys before I throw in the towel on this
one cuz god damn it I'm sweaty as a
[ __ ] pumper ass bag kit titty
piss [ __ ] ass titty poopy poopy in my
pants poopy poopy pants II poop okay
sorry for my foul language I got all
that cursing out of the way so then now
I can be a happy fun family-friendly
entertainer
[Music]
sunshine rainbows at my ass
okay one more time I can't be beaten
like this I gotta end it on a good note
my arms are literally coated with sweat
I should bottle it and sell it on eBay
so all the proceeds to charity right
like comment favorite and subscribe if
you think that's a good idea
that's the oddly enough it probably
raised millions for charity how many of
you out there would pay ten thousand
dollars for a bottle of my sweat I call
it Markham owns because it's markiplier
pheromones that I'm selling you guys
would love it we'll make the ladies go
crazy for you not in a good way but
literally the type of crazy that wants
to stab you in the butt over and not in
that good way either it's all bad all
bad but stabbing all bad pheromones so
who wants it ten thousand dollars a
bottle anybody anybody anybody anybody
I'll give it for free I'll take a to
conventional just spray oh god I didn't
do the right one oh my god I thought I
was dead so bad
I thought I was so dead there okay give
me your stuff oh that's a new boovie
Gaby what is that goobie yeah I saw it
you can't run away from me I saw you my
fists of fury yes someone to make it to
the next level and I'm gonna make it to
sunshine and happiness land I still
don't know what this does but I'm gonna
try it because they haven't survived
long enough to be able to utilize it who
all come on that hit you oh wait a
minute what nautical miles why would I
want to know my progress in miles wall
Adam Megan you goddamn sense Oh some of
the enemies drop gathered goobers as
well
butoh Oh God why does the Saint be so
watch this game Amy Ari I'm done
god damn it I I always set out in these
games I always set out to set a good
example what game plays should be I was
trying to represent the best part of
humanity but in the end I just devolve
into the most guttural and ugly human
that mankind has to offer I am NOT a
good example of humanity but hopefully
you guys like my ramblings if you do let
me know in the comments below thank you
all so much for watching truly you are
all beautiful people and I love you so
much I may not be happy about my
performance but hopefully you got a kick
out of it so anyway thanks again
everybody and as always now we'll see
you in the next video
[Music]